nos dicen una empresa de noticias
locales vende su suscripción impresa por
9 pesos con 30 centavos al mes y tiene
2400 suscriptores a partir de una
encuesta realizada ellos esperan perder
20 suscriptores por cada incremento de
10 centavos al precio actual de
suscripción cuál debe ser el cargo
mensual por suscripción que debe cobrar
la empresa para maximizar el ingreso de
las suscripciones de noticias impresas
pensemos en el ingreso o mejor dicho su
ganancia que es el dinero que obtienen
el ingreso y de ingreso es igual al
número de suscriptores que tienen usamos
ese para suscriptores por el precio por
suscriptor
este va a ser el ingreso en el enunciado
nos dicen que los suscriptores están en
función del precio lo que tiene sentido
porque si aumenta el precio entonces
habrá menos suscriptores y nos dicen que
a partir de una encuesta realizada ellos
esperan perder 20 suscriptores por cada
incremento de 10 centavos al precio
actual de suscripción y el precio actual
de suscripción es de 9 pesos con 30
centavos
veamos si podemos escribir el número de
suscriptores como una función del precio
al precio actual tenemos 2.400
suscriptores pero vamos a perder 20
suscriptores
es decir que restamos 20 suscriptores
por cada 10 centavos por arriba de 9
pesos con 30 centavos multiplicamos esto
por p menos 9 pesos con 30 centavos lo
que nos da el valor absoluto del
incremento en el precio por arriba de 9
pesos con 30 centavos y si queremos
saber cuántos múltiplos de 10 centavos
hay por arriba de 9 pesos con 30
centavos tenemos que dividir esto entre
10 centavos esta parte de aquí nos dice
cuántos múltiplos de 10 centavos hay por
arriba del precio actual y por cada uno
de esos múltiplos vamos a perder 20
suscriptores esta es la parte más
interesante de este problema como
expresamos los suscriptores como una
función del precio porque una vez que
hacemos esto lo sustituimos aquí y
podemos calcular el ingreso solamente
como una función del precio permítanme
mostrarles a qué me refiero con esto
antes de hacerlo vamos a simplificar un
poco esta función
los suscriptores van a ser iguales a
2400 menos 20 entre 0.10 es igual a 200
menos 200 por p menos 9 pesos con 30
centavos distribuimos el 200 y nos queda
que los suscriptores son iguales a 2400
menos 200 p y menos 200 por menos 9.30
es igual a veamos dos por 9.30 es 18
puntos 60 por lo que es igual a 1860
pesos más 1860
fue menos 200 x menos 9.30 ahora sumamos
esto con esto y nos queda sumamos 1000 a
2000 y queda 3000 y 860 más 400 es 1260
nos sumamos todo queda igual a 4 mil 260
menos 200 p ahora tenemos la fórmula
simplificada de los suscriptores como
una función del precio ahora podemos
sustituir esta expresión en lugar de s
en la ecuación original si lo hacemos
queda que el ingreso es igual a
sustituimos s por 4.260 menos 200 pp por
p distribuimos estapé y nos queda el
ingreso como función del precio es igual
a 4 mil 260 p menos 200 por p cuadrada
el ingreso como función del precio queda
como una cuadrática y me gusta escribir
primero los términos de grado mayor por
lo que nos queda que el ingreso es igual
a menos 200 cuadras más 4 mil 260 p es
una cuadrática y es una cuadrática que
se abre hacia abajo
vemos esto porque el término de segundo
grado es negativo por lo que la gráfica
de i como función de p se ve más o menos
así si este es el eje y y este es el eje
p sabemos que la gráfica es una parábola
que abre hacia abajo lo que es bueno
porque queremos encontrar el punto
máximo una parábola que abre hacia abajo
tiene un punto máximo en cambio una
parábola que abre hacia arriba tiene un
punto mínimo pero no un punto máximo
necesitamos encontrar cuál es el precio
en este punto máximo en este precio
estará el vértice o punto máximo de este
problema recordemos cómo podemos
encontrar el vértice de una parábola hay
varias formas de hacerlo pueden
encontrar las raíces pueden encontrar
los valores de x que hacen que esta
función sea igual a cero y el vértice se
encuentra en medio de ambas raíces esta
es una forma de hacerlo otra forma de
hacerlo es decir si tenemos algo con la
forma e iguala a por p cuadrada más b
por p más en lugar de escribir xy use
pues el vértice estará en el negativo
del coeficiente b entre 2 a éste será el
valor de p en donde se encuentra el
vértice el valor de p en este punto es
cuando se alcance el mínimo o el máximo
en una parábola y en este caso será el
máximo a que es igual menos b pues es
este valor de acá menos b es menos 4.260
entre a que es menos 200 por 2 lo que es
menos 400 a que es igual esto negativo /
negativo es igual a positivo esto es lo
mismo que 426 entre 40 veamos si podemos
simplificar lo 40 cabe en 426 diez veces
y sobre 26 son 10 y 26 40 vos
o igual a 10 con 13 20 a vos si queremos
escribir esto en términos de pesos ya
que nos referimos al precio tenemos que
escribir esto en términos de centésimas
por lo que esto es lo mismo que 10 y
multiplicamos el denominador por 5 y el
numerador por 5 y queda igual a 10 con
65 centésimas que es lo mismo que 10
pesos con 65 centavos y por suerte
encontramos esta opción aquí otra forma
en la que pudimos hacer esto es calcular
los valores de pe que hacen que el
ingreso sea 0 y el valor que se
encuentre en medio de estos va a ser el
valor del precio en donde se tiene el
máximo podemos hacer esto al ver la
ecuación original y preguntarnos cuáles
son los valores de pe que hacen que esto
sea 0 que hace que 4.260 por p menos 200
por p cuadrada sea igual a cero vamos a
factorizar p queda por 4.260 menos 200 p
igual a cero así que cuando pese a igual
a cero esto
a ser igual a 0 lo que tiene sentido
porque tenemos ingresos de 0 si no
cobramos nada o cuando 4.260 menos 200 p
sea igual a cero aquí es cuando no
cobramos nada por lo que no tendremos
ingreso y esto es cuando cobramos tanto
que perdemos a todos los suscriptores y
no tenemos ingresos vamos a despejar p
restamos 4.260 en ambos lados y
multiplicamos ambos lados por menos 1 y
queda 200 igual a 4 mil 260 dividimos
ambos lados entre 200 y queda que es
igual a 4 mil 260 entre 200 es este
precio de aquí es el precio en el que
perdemos a todos los suscriptores por lo
que el punto máximo se encuentra entre
estos dos puntos a medio camino entre 0
y esto pues va a ser igual a la mitad de
esto por lo que el punto máximo está en
cuatro mil 260 entre 400 que es
exactamente lo que encontramos antes es
igual a 10 pesos con 65 centavos